kevin costner being a badass with a gun
there's no way this is gonna be a sloppy
ass mess Shh it three days to kill so
three days to kill stars Kevin Costner
he's a CIA agent he has a brain cancer
and [ __ ] Kevin Costner's like I got
nothing to lose rather Amber Heard his
hot ass weirdly dressed but still hot
boss is like you got nothing to lose so
now he's going after a guy named the
albino sounds good right wait there's
more now he has to bond with his
daughter and so there's a lot of
downtime with that sounds okay right but
wait there's more there's a lot of bums
squatting in his apartment that he can't
get rid of so you're gonna hang out with
the bums but you don't really see the
bums but they're there and so on so
forth obviously this movie started out
pretty cool Costner's doing this mission
he's got his crew in the van you know
they're doing surveillance it's going
after this albino guy lady gets her head
crushed by this elevator you're like yes
let's do it then after that happens and
the movie there's there's no segways in
the movie but it goes from one scene to
the next there's nothing linking the
scene he needs information he goes after
this guy to get information fantastic
his wife calls so you know he has to
duct tape the guy's mouth and he's
talking to her he has to go bond with
his daughter then he has to go make up
with his wife because she's pissed at
him for some reason then he stops by to
visit the bombs and you're like who
wrote this example there's this one
scene where his daughter is that this
this rave or some [ __ ] and she's gonna
get molested if not raped in this
bathroom stall Costner goes in there and
just wrecks shot beats the [ __ ] out of
these teens and she wakes up the next
morning on a park bench with Costner
sitting there waiting for her to wake up
he's like hey are you doing you remember
last night and she gets pissed at him
for saving her from being raped in a
bathroom stall and the very next scene
they're bonding again like the very next
scene so like he went on a mission
killed somebody in two days have passed
and now what they're bonding now because
they're not pissed at each other anymore
no very next thing if we didn't live in
the digital age and this was still film
I would go to the manager of the theater
and complain it be like I'm sorry you're
missing an entire reel of this movie
it's gone when this [ __ ] goes down it's
pretty cool to see it go down this weird
comedy mixed in there's some of it works
some of it doesn't costumes working with
Amber Heard the first time in their
arguing
who has a mustache that actually made me
chuckle but after that the movies
completely phoned in this movie just
needed to be toned back there are too
many things going on in this movie had
to take out this this link that all
right makes segways in there if they
polished it up and took some weird
offshoot [ __ ] out it actually would have
been pretty entertaining
did you tell Costner had fun in the role
he played this role up he did the best
he could with it in the end the movies
choppy everything that leads from point
A to point B feels like it goes from
point A to point Dean you're missing a
couple things in between but you're not
the movie feels like a mess it's
unfocused and in the end I was bored
shitless yes three days to kill is
completely forgettable and you are going
to forget it in t-minus one day yep
already forgot movie has a lower grade
for me than Pompeii did Pompeii is like
a guilty pleasure this movies just it's
more guilty alright so three days to
kill have you seen it what did you think
about it whatever you thought comment
below let me know and as always if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more
[Music]